les feux d'antan allumés sur les grèves
permettant aux hommes d'arriver à bon
port en se jouant des pièges et des
dangers de l'obscurité sont devenus
aujourd'hui électricité énergie lumière
énergie puissance l'électricité
omniprésente et indispensable dans la
vie quotidienne
bien que non stockables doit être
disponible partout et tout le temps pour
pouvoir répondre dans un siècle à la
formidable demande en énergie les 13
milliards d'êtres humains de la planète
alors que s'épuiseront peu à peu les
ressources fossiles comme le gaz le
pétrole ou le charbon le nucléaire
énergie de substitution permettra alors
aux villes de conserver leurs lumières
c
avec les années folles de ce début de
xxème siècle c'est l'arrivée dans la vie
quotidienne de toute une série de
technologies nouvelles comme
l'automobile l'aéroplane le téléphone et
surtout l'électricité et ses drôles de
machines
après les années sombres c'est l'heure
de la reconstruction et du développement
spectaculaire de cette nouvelle énergie
dont on ne peut plus passer construction
de barrages hydrauliques et de centrales
thermiques pour produire de
l'électricité mais aussi d'un véritable
réseau pour la distribuer
en 40 ans la consommation d'électricité
en france va se trouver x 20
la fabuleuse aventure du nucléaire
commence il ya un siècle avec la
découverte de la radioactivité par le
physicien français henri becquerel
cinquante ans plus tard grâce à un autre
physicien frédéric joliot c'est la
réalisation de zoé la première pile
atomique française en france le
développement du nucléaire est confiée
en 1945 du commissariat à l'énergie
atomique qui est chargée des recherches
et de la construction des premiers
prototypes
au plan européen c'est en 1957 la
constitution de leurs atomes marché
commun du nucléaire un organisme dont la
mission est le développement
communautaire de l'énergie atomique à
des fins exclusivement civil
en 1956 c'est la construction du
réacteur g1 à marcoule et la production
du premier kilowatt heure nucléaire
français
du prototype on passe alors rapidement à
la phase industrielle avec dans les
années soixante à chinon sur la loire la
construction par edf des trois premières
unités de production d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire
on construira ensuite trois autres
centrales de à saint laurent des eaux et
une au budget
les années 70 sont techniquement
déterminant pour le développement du
nucléaire français qui va abandonner la
filière de l'uranium naturel au profit
de celles utilisant l'uranium enrichi et
l'eau sous pression
autre date importante 1974 et le choc
pétrolier pour être moins dépendants
d'une énergie dont les prix flambent
on décide de remplacer progressivement
les centrales au fioul par des centrales
nucléaires en quinze ans c'est alors la
construction et la mise en service de 53
réacteurs nucléaires dont la puissance
ne cessera d'augmenter au fil des années
avec une énergie électrique provenant à
75% du nucléaire l'objectif fixé en 74
est atteint dès la fin des années 80 et
aujourd'hui l'indépendance énergétique
de la france est proche de 50%
le minerai extrait du sol est trop
pauvre en uranium pour être utilisé tel
quel comme carburant dans les centrales
nucléaires
il faut le concentré en lui faisant
subir toute une série de traitements
chimiques
le produit concentré obtenu contenant 60
à 70 % d'uranium est appelée yellow cake
ce qui veut dire gâteau jaune c'est sous
cette forme de pattes couleurs boutons
d'or que l'uranium qui cuisine de
traitement proche de la mine pour être
commercialisé
l'industrie chimique va faire subir
ensuite à l'uranium toute une série de
purification et transformation avec
notamment la jonction de fluor à l'issue
d'opérations chimie très complexe
l'uranium va devenir tétrafluorure
d'uranium et sa couleur va passer du
jaune au vert
l'uranium est en fait un mélange de deux
isotopes l'uranium 238 et l'uranium 235
fissile offre l'uranium naturel contient
beaucoup d'uranium 238 est
malheureusement très peu d'uranium 235 0
7% seulement
comme pour pouvoir être utilisé dans les
centrales l'uranium doit posséder 3 %
d'uranium 235
il faut donc l'enrichir pour cela on le
fait passer successivement plus de mille
fois à travers des parois poreuses
véritable raffineries du carburant
nucléaire
ces minuscules pastis oxyde d'uranium
qui ne pèse que 7 g vont pouvoir libérer
chacune autant d'énergie qu'une tonne de
charbon
il faut 11 millions de pastilles
assemblée en tube puis en éléments
combustible pour alimenter le coeur
d'une centrale dans le réacteur
les atomes d'uranium vont alors subir
des milliards de milliards de fission
par seconde
conséquence une énorme libération de
chaleur qui atteint 1300 degrés dans le
coeur des noyaux et 300 degrés pour
l'eau pressurisée qui baigne le coeur du
réacteur mais aussi la transformation
même de la matière qui après 3 ans
d'utilisation sera encore constituée à
90 7 % d'uranium avec seulement 3 % de
déchets
renouvelé par tiers chaque année les
éléments combustibles usagés sont
d'abord transférés en zone de stockage
ou après six mois et une radioactivité /
ils sont mis dans un conteneur spécial
appelé château est ainsi transporter en
toute sécurité vers les usines de
retraitement de la hague
après une nouvelle attente de six mois
et la séparation du plutonium et des
produits de fission 95% du combustible
traité restant est composé d'uranium
encore légèrement enrichi à 20% de
l'uranium qui prendra alors à nouveau le
chemin de la raffinerie puis de la
centrale
une vingtaine d'années après le début de
la fabuleuse aventure du nucléaire cette
énergie fournit aujourd'hui 17% de
l'électricité mondiale 40% de
l'électricité en europe occidentale et
on l'a dit 75% de la consommation
française
les raisons du développement
spectaculaire du nucléaire en france
sont très nombreuses volonté politique
de diversifier les sources
d'approvisionnement énergétique parade à
l'épuisement prévisible des ressources
fossiles comme le gaz le charbon le
pétrole manque de productivité d énergie
d'appoint comme le solaire ou l'énergie
éolienne besoins croissants en énergie
et plus récemment les problèmes
d'environnement comme les plus acides ou
l'effet de serre provoquées par la
combustion du charbon du gaz ou du
pétrole
les cinquante trois centrales nucléaires
françaises utilisent l'uranium et l'eau
pressurisée une centrale nucléaire de ce
type
c'est une sorte de grosse bouilloire
dont le circuit d'eau sous pression
prend sa chaleur dans le réacteur et par
l'intermédiaire d'un échangeur le
générateur de vapeur jouve un second
circuit indépendant qui produit de la
vapeur
la vapeur produite dans la centrale fait
tourner une turbine
celle ci entraîne un alternateur qui
produit de l'électricité comme pour
refroidir le condenseur il faut de l'eau
les centrales sont toujours situées à
proximité de la mer ou d'une rivière
une centrale nucléaire de ce type
comporte trois barrières successives
qu'ils à la matière fissile du monde
extérieur une enceinte de confinement en
béton d'un mètre d'épaisseur
une protection qui n'existe pas dans les
centrales du type tchernobyl
à l'intérieur la cuve en acier du
réacteur puis la gaine du combustible
une centrale nucléaire ça se conduit
comme une voiture ça se démarre ça
s'accélère en remontant les bars de
commandes et ça peut même s'arrêter
automatiquement en moins de deux
secondes
en cas de problème
la puissance des centrales françaises et
de 913 sens où 400 mégawatts
le carburant utilisé à pouvoir
énergétique extraordinaire car en la
matière une tonne d'uranium équivaut à
15 mille tonnes de pétrole
aussi ne faudra-t-il ici que 25 tonnes
d'uranium à 3 % face à un million et
demi de tonnes de fuel et plus de 2
millions de tonnes de charbon pour
produire les mêmes 1000 mégawatts
d'électricité
véritable trait d'union entre centrales
de production et les consommateurs ces
autoroutes de l'énergie transport de
l'électricité sous très haute tension
400 mille volts
ce qui à edf ont en charge l'entretien
permanent de ces lignes sous très haute
surveillance
ce sont les lignards des anges gardiens
qui évolue entre ciel et terre
en tout 90 mille kilomètres de lignes
plus de deux fois le tour de la terre
des lignes chargé de transporter une
énergie qui ne se stocke pas
des opérations d'entretien et de
réparation effectuée sans coupure du
courant c'est-à-dire sous 400 mille
volts
une victoire quotidienne sur
l'impossible
ils sont ainsi sept mille à edf a veillé
nuit et jour au transport et à
contribuer à la continuité de
l'alimentation en électricité
je
que faire du combustible usé qu'il faut
chaque année retirées du coeur d'une
centrale de 1000 mégawatts soit on le
stock en l'état et on transmet ainsi nos
ordures aux générations futures avec se
débrouiller soit on le retraite pour le
réutiliser c'est la solution choisie
aujourd'hui par la france le japon
l'allemagne la belgique la suisse et la
grande-bretagne
ce centre de retraitement du nucléaire
c'est celui de la hague en france au
bout de la presqu'île du cotentin
un centre de raffinage où l'on récupère
les produits réutilisables comme
l'uranium et où l'on conditionne sous
forme sur les cendres de la fission
appelé aussi déchets de haute activité
on confond trop souvent ses cendres qui
ne représentent que 3 % d'uranium
utilisé avec les déchets dits de faibles
activités les moins préoccupant mais ce
qu'on regarde plus car ils sont stockés
en surface
ce sont des vêtements des outils des
pièces dont la radioactivité n'est qu'à
l'état de traces mais que par précaution
on enferme dans du béton et qu'on
recouvre de terre c'est à cause d'eux
qu'on appelle parfois la hague la
poubelle du nucléaire pour les
véritables déchets les cendres si l'on
peut dire
après avoir été liquéfié et refroidi
pendant cinq ans ils sont vitrifiés
c'est-à-dire mélangé à un verre spécial
en fusion et emprisonné solide dans un
conteneur d'acier puis stockée dans des
puits souterrains
après avoir exclu un envoi de ses
cendres dans les profondeurs de l'espace
ou dans celle des fonds marins on a
décidé en france de développer les
recherches en la matière en y consacrant
un budget de 15 milliards de francs
recherches fondamentales permettant
peut-être un jour de les faire
disparaître définitivement par
incinération études géologiques poussée
du sous sol afin de s'assurer qu'on
pourra en toute sécurité d'ici une
quinzaine d'années et entreposer ces
déchets jusqu'à la nuit des temps si le
site de soulaines dans l'aube à d'ores
et déjà été retenues pour y entreposer
les déchets faiblement radioactifs
on étudie comme dans tous les pays du
monde les moyens les plus appropriés
pour le stockage des déchets à vie
longue est les premiers combustible usé
venus de l'étranger et traités à la
hague devrait repartir sous forme de
déchets conditionné et de matières
nucléaires réutilisables dès 1994 dans
leur pays d'origine comme le japon la
belgique ou l'allemagne
mais déjà on travaille sur des
techniques du futur appelé retraitement
vous c'est l'espoir un jour de pouvoir
aller encore plus loin dans leur
traitement
la séparation de nouveaux éléments et
leur incinération un recyclage de type
nouveau comme celui qu'on fait
aujourd'hui subir au plutonium
permettant d'éviter d'enfouir certains
radioéléments à vie longue
lorsqu'on parle de sûreté nucléaire la
question sur toutes les lèvres est bien
sûr un tel accident
est il possible en france réponse des
experts l'accident est possible avec des
rejets de l'ordre du centième de ceux de
tchernobyl mais avec les mesures en
vigueur
il est très peu probable reste qu'on ne
pourra jamais dire qu'il est impossible
à la centrale de flamanville près du
havre comme partout ailleurs en france
on a tiré les leçons des deux accidents
majeurs du nucléaire dans le monde
ceux de three mile island aux états unis
et de tchernobyl en ex urss à 6
aujourd'hui pour edf la moitié du prix
de revient d'un kilowattheure et le prix
payé pour la sécurité première règle
d'or on la vit une triple barrière
étanche de sécurité que sont la gaine la
cuve et l'enceinte de confinement
des panneaux de contrôle plus lisible et
mieux hiérarchiser ainsi que la présence
permanente dans la centrale d'un
ingénieur de sûreté radioprotection dont
le rôle est de doubler le diagnostic de
l'équipe de quart ce sont de nouvelles
mesures de sûreté appliqué aujourd'hui
dans le nucléaire français
le centre nerveux d'une centrale ces six
équipes de quart qui se relaient toutes
les huit heures pour piloter 24 heures
sur 24 le réacteur mais aussi des
rosiers qui vérifie en permanence
vannes soupapes et tuyauteries une
centrale c'est un millier de personnes
astreintes à des règles draconiennes de
sécurité
cet examen minutieux des soudures de la
cuve du réacteur par un robot cela fait
partie des contrôles annuels de sécurité
lors des arrêts programmés de la
centrale contrôle quotidien annuel
tous les cinq ans et tous les dix ans
avec la remise à neuf de tous les
éléments vitaux une révision générale
qui dure quatre mois grâce à un
entretien très poussé les centrales
françaises devraient fonctionner pendant
40 ans avec un niveau de sécurité qui
s'améliore constamment avec l'expérience
acquise en france et dans le monde
en france c'est l'exploitant edf qui est
responsable de la sécurité des centrales
mais deux organismes dépendant des
ministères de l'industrie de
l'environnement et de la santé
contrôler en permanence son activité et
peuvent à tout moment ordonné l'arrêt de
la centrale
s'il juge que la sécurité n'est plus
assurée dans les centrales nucléaires
françaises
la transparence de l'information est
désormais la règle protection
surveillance prévention et formation
c'est sur ces quatre principes tu
reposes leur sûreté
à temps
c'est énorme cheminée et leurs épais
panaches blancs font désormais partie de
notre paysage
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas il ne
s'agit pas là de pollution nucléaire
mais bien des recharges et d'humidité
est complètement dépourvu de tout
radioactivité ici pas de dégagement de
gaz carbonique c'est à dire pas de gaz à
effet de serre ni de plus acides
les centrales nucléaires consommatrices
d'eau la rejette dans le voisinage
immédiat après utilisation série le
contrôle sanitaire avant rejet mais
aussi après et des contrôles
particulièrement sur l'herbe et le lait
des exploitations alentours
prélèvement et surveillance régulière
également de l'air et de l'eau de pluie
en fonctionnement normal tout centrale
rejette en effet de faibles quantités de
produits radioactifs sous forme d qu en
liquide ou gazeuse dont les valeurs
doivent toujours resté très inférieur au
seuil prescrit par le ministère de la
santé
centrales nucléaires sous haute
surveillance écologique avec ici l'étude
des mesures à apporter pour atténuer
certaines nuisances sonores
comme pour les rivières on l'a vu les
eaux rejetées en mer sont analysés en
permanence
bien maîtrisé seydou légèrement
réchauffées peut contribuer au
développement d'utilisation
économiquement intéressantes comme
l'aquaculture ou l'exploitation de
véritables serres horticoles chauffée à
bon marché
les centrales nucléaires françaises
accueille 350 mille visiteurs par an
le nucléaire c'est d'abord sur le plan
économique une moindre dépendance du
pétrole et du dollar qui sert à le payer
le nucléaire c'est aussi une garantie
d'approvisionnement permanent et de
stabilité économique pour une énergie
dont le prix en france n'a fait que
baisser depuis dix ans
au niveau européen c'est
l'interconnexion des réseaux ce qui veut
dire échanges car l'électricité circule
depuis longtemps librement à travers les
frontières de l'europe
avec un chiffre d'affaires de 12
milliards de francs
la france est devenu exportateur
d'électricité edf le septième
exportateurs français
disposer à tout moment de l'énergie
électrique dont on a besoin
sans se soucier ni du temps qu'il fait
dehors ni du lieu où l'on se trouve
c'est ça aussi la fabuleuse aventure du
nucléaire